und damit kommen wir zum größten
einzelplan arbeit und soziales und die
debatte findet gleich ihren anfang mit
bundesminister hubertus heil
ein bisschen zeit hat er noch denn sie
sehen es die abgeordneten müssen erst
einmal zu ihren platz kommen denn es ist
meine sehr geehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen unser land steht zweifelsohne
vor großen wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
herausforderungen vor einigen diesem
herbst winter auch im nächsten jahr
viele menschen machen sich sorgen wie
sie ihre rechnungen bezahlen viele vor
allem kleinere und mittelständische
unternehmen angst davor dass
energiekosten auf der anderen seite
fehlende konsum nachfrage ihr geschäft
beschädigt und viele menschen machen
sich auch schon wieder sorgen was das
für ihre arbeitsplätze bedeutet die
ursache dafür das dürfen wir in dieser
debatte nicht vergessen dass die
tatsache dass wir erleben dass energie
als waffe eingesetzt wird als waffe um
den sozialen frieden zu untergraben
genau das ist putins kalkül ich bin mir
sicher wahrer größe der herausforderung
des vereins miteinander hinbekommen
müssen putin wird unsere gesellschaft
nicht spalten unterschätzt den sozialen
zusammenhalt dieser gesellschaft und
darum geht es auch in dieser debatte
denn es ja nachzulesen was er versucht
westliche demokratien zu stabilisieren
nicht nur die ukrainische überfallen
sondern uns zu sprechen aber ich will
ihnen sagen warum ich trotz aller größe
dieser herausforderung unterschätzte
überhaupt niemand was das für eine große
ist
zuversichtlich bin dass wir deutschland
sicher durch diesen winter bringen
können denn zum einen haben wir seit
anbeginn dieser bundesregierung alles
getan um die gasversorgung in
deutschland zu sichern die speicher zu
füllen ersatz zu beschaffen dafür zu
sorgen dass die vierte stufe einer gas
notlage nicht ausgelöst werden muss und
dass es knappheiten gibt die zur
verteilungskonflikten zwischen
wirtschaft und verbrauchern führt ist
eine ganz ganz wichtige nachricht und
ich finde der bundeskanzler hat er sehr
eindrucksvoll in seiner rede in dieser
woche deutlich gemacht so harte arbeiten
in st
und klar ist auch wir müssen was tun
damit die preise bei energie runtergehen
beim strommarkt hat die koalition
beschlossen oder strompreis bremse dafür
zu sorgen dass wir eben nicht durch
zufall zu der über gewinne im strommarkt
designs zu lassen das ist der strompreis
noch weiter steigt und wir werden auch
beim gaspreis maßnahmen ergreifen aber
meine damen und herren
trotz alledem sind die energiekosten
hoch und die tatsache dass auch
allgemeinen lebenshaltungskosten viele
menschen belasten sind aufgaben die wir
uns zu stellen haben und deshalb haben
wir mittlerweile
entlastungspaket von fast 100 milliarden
euro auf den weg gebracht um gezielt vor
allem menschen mit mittleren und unteren
einkommen zu entlasten dazu gehört dass
wir zum ersten januar die regelsätze
anpassen werden in der grundsicherung im
neuenbürger gilt dazu gehört die größte
wohngeldreform die es in dieser republik
gegeben hat und mieterinnen und mieter
mit geringem einkommen zu unterstützen
auch mit einem heizkosten zum schlag
nochmals dazu gehört dass wir an
geringverdiener gedacht werden indem wir
dafür sorgen dass menschen die weniger
als 2000 euro verdienen nicht nur
erleben dass die erhöhung des
mindestlohns der ja auch zum ersten
oktober auf 12 euro gehen wird mehr geld
in der tasche haben sondern wir werden
ihnen durch eine senkung von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
auch mehr geld in der tasche lassen und
das ohne dass der soziale schutz im
bereich der midi jobs mich für die
beschäftigten verringern
ich bin froh dass wir mit den
beschlüssen der koalition nicht nur
entlastung haben für arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer mit der energie geld
pauschale die jetzt zum ersten september
kommt und auch an selbstständige gedacht
haben sondern dass wir es auch
hinkriegen dass studierende das fach
schülerinnen fachschüler und dass auch
die 22 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentner in deutschland unterstützung
bekommen die 300 euro werden an kommen
meine damen und herren das haben wir in
der koalition beschlossen
das kindergeld wird angepasst auch der
kinderzuschlag
wird erhöht und meine damen und herren
es ist wichtig dass wir auch an die
arbeiten damit in diesem land denken
deshalb stehe ich zu den steuerlichen
beschlossen die wir gefasst haben es
geht nicht darum dass wir einzelne
gruppen im blick haben es geht darum die
gesamte gesellschaft im blick zu haben
und dafür zu sorgen dass diese
gesellschaft nicht durch putins krieg
zerrissen wird das ist unsere aufgabe
der stellen wir uns
wir müssen aber auch die wirtschaftliche
substanz und die arbeitsplätze durch
diesen winter bringen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass mein kollege robert habeck
heute in seiner rede in seinem teil
deutlich gemacht hat dass ein
schutzschirm auch für mittelständische
unternehmen erweitern werden und ich
werde meinen beitrag leisten auch in
dieser zeit dafür zu sorgen
arbeitsplätze zu sichern deshalb kann
ich ihnen an dieser stelle sagen wir
werden am nächsten mittwoch im kabinett
beschließen nicht nur das für den
vereinfachten zugang zur kurzarbeit in
diesem sommer in diesem winter weiter
verlängern sondern wir werden den
deutschen bundestag auch bitten uns alle
handlungsoptionen für eine
wirtschaftliche eskalation im bereich
der kurzarbeit zu geben dass es uns in
der korona zeit gut gelungen denn corona
war ja nicht nur die größte
gesundheitskrise und ist es unserer
generation sondern auch die tiefste
wirtschaftskrise und trotzdem haben wir
den deutschen arbeitsmarkt robust durch
diese krise gebracht millionen von
arbeitsplätzen gesichert und das will
ich dass uns das auch in schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen zeiten gelingt deshalb
wird die brücke der kurzarbeit auch in
diesem winter den beschäftigten
unternehmen in deutschland zur verfügung
stehen
es geht also um eine ernste situation
und es ist vollkommen legitim dass in
diesem hause jedenfalls unter den
demokratischen parteien über mittel und
wege und instrumente gestritten wird das
ist in einer demokratie vollkommen
glücklich aber ich bitte sie bei einem
streit um das einzel nicht zu vergessen
wir unser eigentlich ergebnis sitzt in
moskau über diese gesellschaft spalten
er wird uns verunsichern er wird uns von
der solidarität zur ukraine abbringen
und das werden wir nicht zulassen dürfen
als gesellschaft deshalb bekräftige ich
was ich kurz nach den 24 februar von
diesem pult ausgesagt habe ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass ist die gesamte
bundesregierung dass die gesamte
koalition ich glaube die meisten
demokraten ja auch im hause äußere
sicherheit und innerer sozialer friede
sind zwei seiten derselben medaille das
müssen wir im blick auf die
herausforderung vor uns haben wir werden
uns nicht spalten lassen und wir werden
diese gesellschaft zusammenhalten
trotz aller kraft die wir daran setzen
diese krise zu meistern diese
bewährungsprobe für unser land
wirtschaftlich und sozial zu bewältigen
dürfen wir dabei nicht vernachlässigen
dass dieses gesetz diese gesellschaft
nicht nur krisen management braucht
sondern sie braucht auch fortschritt und
deshalb werden wir themen nicht auf die
lange bank schieben die wir uns als
koalition für die wirtschaftliche und
soziale erneuerung dieses landes
vorgenommen haben wir haben gestern beim
fachkräfte gipfel beispielsweise darüber
gesprochen dass wir im blick auf den
demografischen wandel dafür sorgen
müssen dass langfristig nicht wie wir
das jetzt schon in vielen branchen und
regionen in deutschland erleben der
mangel an arbeit zu den fachkräften zur
dauerhaften wachstums und wohlstands
preise für deutschland werden darf und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass sie gestern
mit wirtschaft und gewerkschaften mit
bund und ländern und in der koalition
uns auf konkrete maßnahmen verständigt
haben um die inländischen potenziale in
diesem land voll zu erschließen dazu
gehört dafür zu sorgen dass wir mit
einer ausbildungsgarantie dafür sorgen
dass möglichst alle jungen menschen eine
chance auf berufliche ausbildung haben
dazu gehört berufsorientierung wenn es
nach mir geht ab der fünften klasse an
jeder schulform dazugehört mobilitäts
dazu gehörten angebot von betrieblichen
ausbildungsstellen aber dazu gehört im
notfall in unterversorgten gebieten auch
überbetriebliche ausbildung es geht um
den ausbau der jungen berufs kennt uhren
den wir uns vorgenommen haben es geht
darum menschen den berufsabschluss
verpasst haben mit dem bürgergeld reform
eine chance zu geben einen
berufsabschluss nachzuholen bei der
bürger geht es nicht nur um die frage
der sozialen unterstützung der
entbürokratisierung das ist auch wichtig
es geht darum dass wir menschen und zwei
drittel der langzeitarbeitslosen haben
keine abgeschlossene berufsausbildung
eine neue chance eröffnen und im
zweifelsfall sie nicht in irgendwelche
hilfstätigkeiten drücken und das
jobcenter sieht sie dann nach ein paar
wochen oder monaten wieder sondern dafür
zu sorgen dass sie ein anreiz haben
finanziell aber auch die möglichkeit
einen berufsabschluss nachzuholen auch
das ein beitrag zur fachkräfte bezogen
wir werden zudem fallen die frauen
erwerbsbeteiligung deutschland erhöhen
müssen und auch menschen die
eingeschränkt sind als chance für
unseren arbeitsmarkt begreifen und hören
abbauen und wir werden gleichzeitig
qualifizierte zuwanderung mit einem
modernen einwanderungsgesetz für
deutschland schaffen das ist
wohlstandssicherung meine damen und
herren auch über die krise hinaus die
wir betreiben werden ich hätte gern noch
ein bisschen mehr zeit und ihn auch noch
deutlich zu machen was die bürger geld
wo form ist das werden meine kolleginnen
kollegen machen ich will ihnen auch
sagen dass in diesem jahr auch noch die
sicherung des rentenniveaus über 2020
hinaus machen werden sie sehen also
diese koalition hat die kraft und die
entschlossenheit nicht nur diese krise
für deutschland zu meistern sondern auch
für zukunft zu sorgen herzlichen dank
gehört deshalb bundesminister für arbeit
und soziales hatte unter anderem
fachkräfte gipfel angesprochen er mit
dem wirtschafts bildungs und
arbeitsministerium hier eher wirken
möchte dass es nicht zum
fachkräftemangel kommt bis zum jahr 2026
so schätzt die bundesregierung fehlen
240.000 fachkräfte in deutschland auch
unsere wirtschaft und unser sozialstaat
machen zurzeit einen dramatischen
stresstest durch die pandemie ist noch
nicht überwunden da treffen uns die
folgen von putins angriffskrieg und die
energiepreis explosion mit großer wucht
zugleich dürfen wir nicht vergessen viel
viel härter trifft dieser krieg die
menschen in der ukraine selbst täglich
sterben dort frauen männer und kinder
wir wollen den erfolg der ukraine als
voraussetzung für den frieden
und ich danke allen in unserem land sich
jetzt für die vielen flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine und für die unterstützung der
ukraine selbst einsetzen für ihren
ausdrucksstarken großartigen einsatz wir
wollen dass unser sozialstaat diese
herausforderung gut meistert wer auf
einen dramatischen winter hofft wer will
dass aus der sorgen vieler menschen wut
wird der versagt politisch und der
versagt moralisch und er hat für sein
schäbiges tun eine klare antwort aller
demokratinnen und demokraten verdient
meine damen meine herren wir
unterstützen alle sinnvollen maßnahmen
die monot vieler menschen zu lindern gut
dass nun auch rentnerinnen und rentner
studentinnen und studenten eine
einmalzahlung erhalten wir haben dies
nachdrücklich gefordert wir hätten uns
eine
gezieltere einmalzahlung gewünscht mehr
geld für die die bis weit in die mitte
unserer gesellschaft hinein jeden cent
umdrehen müssen keine unterstützung für
die die sie nicht brauchen
ein guter ansatz ist es sonderzahlung
von steuern und abgaben zu befreien wenn
sich sozialpartner darauf eingehen das
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich hoffentlich
nutzen viele betriebe dies hoffentlich
können sie es auch nutzen gar nicht zu
diesen maßnahmen passt eine gas umlage
die die bürgerinnen und bürger und die
wirtschaft belastet um auch unternehmen
zugute zu kommen die die es gar nicht
brauchen wie sagt der spd kollegin der
krise
handwerkliche umsetzung bedenklich und
am ende zahlt der bürger drauf ende des
zitats sie hätten heute diesen unsinn
stoppen können sie hätten heute diesen
unsinn stoppen müssen schade dass sie
dies nicht getan
gerade in der krise muss um jeden
arbeitsplatz gekämpft werden am samstag
hat enorm mag heißt ein neues die
aluminiumhütte rheinberg ihr 60 jähriges
bestehen gefeiert
doch beim gespräch mit betriebsratschef
und werksleiter war uns nicht nach
unbeschwerten feiern zumute denn es
zeichnete sich ab was heute gewissheit
ist ein rückgang der produktion ein
zurückfahren der produktion um 50
prozent das warten auf lösungen bei
strompreis und gaspreis bedeutet für
diese unternehmen das bangen um den
fortbestand vieler arbeitsplätze und
dies gilt erst recht für viele klein-
und mittelständische betriebe in dieser
lage ist es unverantwortlich nicht alle
möglichkeiten der eigenen stromerzeugung
zu nutzen um der preisentwicklung
entgegenzuwirken eine dame
wenn wir die sozialpolitische debatte
des sommers uns betrachten kann man
viele überschriften wortgeklingel und
mancher koalitionsstreit in der ampel zu
erleben sie haben ja das bürgergeld
angesprochen herr minister
vorgestellt von der fdp sofort um
nachvollziehbar kritisiert im hinblick
auf die neuberechnung der regelsätze und
dem weitgehenden verzicht auf sanktionen
und zwar zu recht denn es wäre falsch
das verhältnis von grundsicherung und
arbeitsentgelten grundsätzlich zu ändern
das hat der koalitionsausschuss das hat
der koalitionsausschuss nun ja auch
abgeräumt der negieren beschluss steht
ausdrücklich bei im übrigen
unveränderter systematik solle und
darüber können wir reden über eine
schnellere inflationsanpassung geredet
werden wie sie wissen lehnen wir die
weitgehende abschaffung der möglichkeit
der durchsetzung von
mitwirkungspflichten ab der landkreistag
waren zu recht eindringlich vor
schritten hin zu einem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen
und der kollege der kollege johannes
vogel der kollege vor johannes vogel hat
wörtlich zu einem fairen bürgergeld
erklärt dazu gehöre das zitat an dem vom
verfassungsgericht bestätigten umfang
von sanktionen festgehalten wird zitat
ende wo er recht hat hat er recht hat
sie aber nennen das einknicken vor
mitwirkungs verweigerer auch noch
vertrauens zeit das ist absurd das
sollte so nicht umgesetzt werden meine
damen meine herren
ja es gibt dinge zu tun der
revisionsbericht der bundesagentur für
arbeit zeigt die maßnahmen der
unterstützung begleitung und förderung
müssen zielgerichteter werden wichtiger
als neue titel und prämien sind
maßnahmen die aus sicht der menschen die
sie zu ihm gehen auch sinn machen hier
ist harte arbeit erforderlich und nicht
einfaches dort geklingelt und wir müssen
eben bei 1,9 millionen offenen stellen
alles tun menschen in ausbildung und
arbeit zu vermitteln und was tun sie sie
kürzen bei der integration in arbeit um
600 millionen euro ein völlig falscher
schritt
der arbeitsminister das thema
fachkräftemangel angesprochen und
fachkräfte zuwanderung wird ja
jedenfalls noch bewusst sein dass wir in
der letzten legislaturperiode ein
modernes fachkräfte einwanderungsrecht
geschaffen haben ist deswegen die arbeit
erledigt nein wir müssen viel tun um
attraktiver zu werden
schnellere visaverfahren mehr
spracherwerb schnellere
berufsanerkennung
dies wird mit neuen überschriften nicht
gelesen sondern nur mit harter arbeit
dazu sollten sie bereit sein und ein
anderes beispiel sei genannt ja ich
begrüße es wenn die fdp im sommer stolz
über die aktien rente geredet hat ich
hätte mir gewünscht die spd es in der
letzten legislaturperiode hier
versprechen mit uns einen neustart in
der privaten altersversorgung umzusetzen
auch getätigt aber jetzt sind sie so
stolz auf das erreichte wo ist es denn
im haushalt wo sind denn die zehn
milliarden im zweiten haushalt dieser
ampel kein cent eingestellt und jeder
weiß zehn milliarden in einen
kapitalstock sind kaum in der lage
zinserträge zu erwirtschaften die bei
300 milliarden euro rentenausgaben eine
signifikante rolle spielen sie reden
schön aber sie tun zu wenig und so
werden sie ihrer sozialen verantwortung
nicht gerecht meine damen meine herren
die kritik vom stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der unions
fraktion hermann gröhe war dass auf ihn
antworten direkt kann nun im markus
kurth für bündnis 90/die grünen sitzt er
im haushaltsausschuss und im ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales
ich bin zwar christ aber
bleibe bei den grün herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eher
gröhe ich glaube wir müssen aus
gegebenen anlass mal über das
menschenbild sprechen das uns
offensichtlich hier trennt die
ampelkoalition und sie und über die
haltung mit der wir menschen gegenüber
treten die
unverschuldet in not sind lange keine
arbeit haben und das wissen sie ganz
genau zum überwiegenden teil verzweifelt
arbeit suchen wir von der ampel gehen
zunächst einmal von der haltung her von
zutrauen vertrauen von bewegung aus und
wir wollen die talente wecken die jedem
menschen schlummern und wollen ihn
befähigen wir sehen in menschen die auf
sozialgesetzbuch zwei leistungen
angewiesen sind keine kostgänger oder
betrüger sondern personen die wenn man
sie unterstützen einen super beitrag für
diese gesellschaft leisten können
und sie treten hier mit unterstellungen
missgunst und als erstes mit der
vermutung hier an dass das personen
seien jedenfalls zu beträchtlichen teil
die gar nicht arbeiten wollten und
dieser tage dieser tage das ist die
unterstellung die in ihre der subtexte
bei ihnen mit schwingt und es gibt
andere die sagen sogar sehr deutlich auf
diese art und weise markus söder hat
diese woche auf einem volksfest in
gillamoos gesagt das solle keiner geld
bekommen wäre würde ich es zitat gerne
in der tonne liegt und in diogenes
spielt zitat ende also ich frage mich
wirklich wie verkommen und wie
niederträchtig muss man sein um vor
einem gründen schon am vormittag
betrunkenen publikum auf kosten der
schwächsten dumme pseudo witze zu machen
jetzt sucht natürlich jeder sein niveau
machen sie das aber die wahrheit ist
praktisch niemand im arbeitslosengeld 2
bezug liegt in der tonne gerne und
spielt diogenes im gegenteil die
realität sieht so aus dass die person
rechnen müssen dass viele von denen auch
versagens erfahrungen oder misserfolg
erfahrungen hinter sich haben abgelehnte
bewerbungen viele auch sie haben selber
angesprochen verfügen nicht über eine
berufsausbildung an der minister hat
angesprochen ein viertel ja nicht
überall über einen schulabschluss es ist
ein großes problem lage erst recht wenn
kinder da sind
und personen die an dieser weise
probleme haben sich selbst zu helfen
haben alles verdient dass wir sie
unterstützen und das ist auch die
zielsetzung von unserem bürgergeld und
diese aufmunternde und unterstützende
haltung eint alle drei parteien die
diese koalition bilden
und ich sage ihnen die sanktion das geht
ja auch von einer doppelten lüge aus
diese geräte das eine ist ja tatsächlich
dass die grundsicherung beziehen
arbeiten wollen was unterschlagen wird
und das zweite ist wir werden da hier
kein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
einführen und die sanktionen abschaffen
das stimmt doch gar nicht haben eine
sechsmonatige vertrauens zeit vereinbart
in der koalition und es geht es geht
darum dass man erst mal grundsätzlich
zunächst nicht für ewig auf der basis
von vertrauen eine arbeitsbeziehung
zwischen jobcenter fallmanagerin und
fallmanagern und hilfebedürftigen
beginnt und andere
vereinfachungsregelung und verschiedenes
regelungen sind gleichzeitig das will
ich sagen sind bürokratieabbau das sagen
die jobcenter selbst wenn man nicht
gleich vom ersten tag oder in einem
halben jahr bereits die angemessenheit
der wohnung prüfen muss dann hat man
keine fähigkeiten und kapazitäten
jobcenter
das meiner darf man keine kapazitäten
mehr im jobcenter oben sich um die
arbeitsaufnahme und qualifikationen zu
bemühen sagen die jobcenter selbst
und ich sage ihnen auch fähigkeit aufbau
arbeitskräfte entwicklung ist
wirtschaftspolitik das stichwort
arbeitskräftemangel ist hier gefallen
wir können es uns nicht leisten ein
signifikantes erwerbspersonenpotenzial
brachliegen zu lassen und an den und an
der stelle muss man natürlich den
konsolidierungsbeitrag den dieser
vorliegende haushaltsentwurf ja auch
erkennbar
leistet eingliederungstitel das wort ist
hier gerade seitens der union in
zwischenruf gefallen muss man sich
natürlich darauf hin noch einmal genau
angucken ob es diesem ziel der
mobilisierung des
erwerbspersonenpotenzials auch wirklich
gerecht wird das gilt auch das gilt auch
für den konsolidierungsbeitrag der im
moment verzeichnet ist bei der
berufsbezogenen sprachförderung von
zuwanderinnen und zuwanderern das ist
eine das ist eine entwicklung die dort
festgeschrieben ist im haushalt die ist
gemacht worden als es die ukraine krieg
und die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
überwiegend ja auch qualifizierte frauen
noch nicht gab ich glaube wir würden uns
wirklich ein schaden zufügen als
bundesrepublik deutschland als
volkswirtschaft wenn wir auch diese
arbeitskräfte nicht nur in ihrem eigenen
sinne sondern auch für unsere wirtschaft
nicht nutzen beziehungsweise nutzen hört
sich gemein an befähigen würden dass wir
hier an dieser stelle auch zum guten
zusammenleben in diesem land kommen und
wenn sie es nicht verstanden haben
wiederhole ich noch einmal für sie die
berufsbezogene deutschförderung werden
wir uns nochmal genau angucken denn das
ist eine wichtige brücke zur stärkung
von beschäftigung und
beschäftigungsfähigkeit
es wird alles nicht zum nulltarif zu
haben sein werde unendliches tun können
aber wir tun alles um die würde und die
zukunft von menschen hier zu
unterstützen an dieser stelle mit diesem
haushalt und in diesem sinne freue ich
mich auf die gemeinsamen beratung vielen
dank
zum schluss wurde markus kurth dann doch
wieder versöhnlicher ist hier in seiner
rede unter anderem öfters bürgergeld
eingegangen dass hier ab dem ersten
januar hartz4 ablösen soll unter anderem
mit einer größeren grundsicherung von
rund 500 euro pro monat
jugend wohl spricht als nächster
mitglied der afg fraktion
herr präsident
verehrte kollegen wie hat die bürger zu
hause und den geräten
der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf ist ein
haushalt der konzept- und
ahnungslosigkeit zeigt das links-grüne
kasse nicht in den zahlen oder kann die
zerstrittenheit der ampel koalition
hinter die kulissen nicht verdecken es
ist ein haushalt der ideologen träume
und kostgänger nicht aber ein haushalt
der fleißigen und vernünftigeren upland
kurz oben eine skandalöse
realitätsverweigerung kennzeichnet
diesen haushalt was ist realität in
deutschland heute
realität sind die vergessenen rentner
also jeder teil des volkes der dieses
land aufgebaut hatte die wohlstand der
wirtschaft es sind die leistungsträger
von gestern die nicht glauben können
dass sie sich nach einem arbeitsreichen
leben mit fragen des heizens im winter
oder strom stammt aufgrund nicht mehr
bezahlbare energie richtung befassen
müssen meine damen und herren der
regierung die energiearmut befeuert die
altersarmut und das ist das
zwischenergebnis
ihre ampel regierung
ihre herrischen 300 euro reichen niemals
um die preissteigerung bei lebensmitteln
kraftstoffe heizöl direkte energie
auszugleichen
aber nicht nur die renten auch ein
großteil der heute in dem aber es nicht
mehr wie es weitergeht
existenzängste erfassen die
mittelschicht sowie die party der
paritätische wohlfahrtsverband zu recht
von millionen arbeitnehmern aus die in
diesem winter in allen fällen werden
die untersten 30 prozent der einkommen
auf der einkommensskala haben keine
rücklagen und werben für die verkorkste
energie und sanktionspolitik zur kasse
die
rund 40
hat euch
kurzarbeiter bälle die auf uns zukommt
die morgens schon an brechen kann wenn
die betriebe die leute lieber nach hause
schicken als mit hohen kosten arbeiten
zu lassen hierauf hatte einzelplan elf
überhaupt keine antwort stattdessen
können wir uns luxus
wir können uns die einwahl nur noch 1000
kalina das arbeitslosengeld 2
wir verschenken teure rüstungsproduktion
ein kriegsgebiet wir können uns ein
unheilvolles bürgel das so deutlich in
zeiten von fachkräftemangel und über
belastenden sozial kräften geben dürfte
dann habe ich nicht verstanden geweiht
ist ein grundeinkommen ohne
sanktionsmöglichkeit der
arbeitsverwaltung dafür haben sie ein
falsches menschen will vor sie haben ein
sozialistisches menschenbild vorsicht
sie sehe die soziale hängematte und
wollte leute dorthin liegen das ist das
und dies auf kosten der steuerzahler und
das ist falsch
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich recht
auch mein wahlkreis 1
der kyffhäuserkreis
er gehört zu den landkreisen in den
prozentual am meisten
mit pendlern wollen sie zu hören wenn
sie nicht zuhören wollen dass der
ausgang gut da mischen wir kommen zurück
zu meinem wahlkreis den kyffhäuserkreis
gehört für die landkreise mit dem
prozentual meisten berufspendler in
deutschland die menschen brauchen arbeit
die arbeit muss mit dem kfz davor haben
werden ostdeutschland mit seiner energie
und öl abhängigen infrastruktur darf
nicht das erste opfer einer gänzlich
verfehlte links grüne energiewende sein
sie müssen schnell höhe um gefunden das
credo der alternative deutschland ist
arbeit schützt an dessen vorhaben das
ist es sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
stehen vor rekord die das land noch
nicht gesehen hat da können sie
dazwischen eine von der politik
vorsätzlich herbeigeführte energie und
wirtschaftskrise erfasst breite
bevölkerungsschichten und die regierung
stolperte ihn entwicklung hinterher
meine damen und herren von den
regierungsparteien
wir brauchen keine halbherzigen
entlastungspaket brauchen wir nicht
eröffnen sie stattdessen dorf stream
zweiter beenden sie die unsinnigen
aktionen die nur deutsche bürger die
deutsche wirtschaft schädigen
produzieren sie strom mit den
vorhandenen kraftwerke deal
atomkraftwerken und meine damen und
herren von der regierung ich erinnere an
ihren amtseid erfüllen sie ihn wenn sie
schaden vom deutschen volke dann
irgendwo war das für die afc fraktion
claudia
physischen spricht jetzt für die fdp
auch sie ist mitglied im haushalts und
finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen seit zwei
jahren befinden wir uns nun im
krisenmodus mit krone und der ukraine
uns beschäftigt nicht nur die
exorbitante inflation sondern wir
stecken auch in einer gravierenden
energiekrise und stehen vor großen
demographischen herausforderungen kein
haushalt ist so unmittelbar von den
daraus resultierenden konsequenzen
betroffen wie der etat des einzuplanen
die gesamtsumme der ausgaben für das
jahr 2023 beläuft sich jetzt schon auf
rund 163 milliarden euro und damit auf
rund 2,2 milliarden euro mehr als im
haushalt 22 im gesamtbudget sgb 2 steht
im haushaltsjahr 23 2 im soll weniger
zur verfügung als im haushaltsjahr 22
aufgrund der rest der regelung und es
passiv aktiv transfers bewegen wir uns
aber weiterhin auf hohem niveau und
bietet ihren hier bedarfsgerecht das
bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales leistet damit seinen beitrag
beitrag zur vereinbarten
haushaltskonsolidierung wir nutzen die
uns zur verfügung stehenden mitteln noch
effizienter und das ist gerade in den
aktuellen zeiten wirklich wichtig im
vergleich zum jahr 2019 also dem vor
corona niveau und unter einbeziehung der
ausgabereste pro erwerbstätigen
leistungsberechtigten stehen pro kopf
sogar rund
170 euro mehr zur verfügung
kommen wir zur rente die leistungen des
bundes an die rentenversicherung steigen
steigen gegenüber dem vorjahr deutlich
um 4,1 milliarden euro auf knapp
113 milliarden euro auch wenn es sich
bei diesen ansätzen um mittel für
gesetzliche pflicht leistung man dazu
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass uns der
demografische wandel vor enorme
herausforderungen stellen wird wir
werden diese welle nicht mit immer mehr
geld aus den staatskassen brechen können
das bekräftigt auch der
bundesrechnungshof der das sagt dass der
automatismus zwischen dem greifen der
beitragssatz garantie und erhöhung des
bundeszuschusses durchbrochen werden
sollte
das geht aber nur wenn gesetzlich
nachgebessert wird
ein wort noch zum kurzarbeitergeld es
ist eines der erfolgreichsten
instrumente im baukasten des modernen
sozialstaats und hat sich in den
hochphasen der korona pandemie mit lok
downs und ausgangssperren gewährt die
aktuell geltenden sonderregeln zum
erleichterten zugang gelten
glücklicherweise noch bis zum ende
dieses jahres dürfen aber nicht zum
dauerzustand werden denn wenn sich die
konjunktur wieder gut entwickelt und der
arbeitsmarkt aufnahmefähig bleibt dann
ist es wichtig dass die arbeitskräfte
auf dem arbeitsmarkt zur verfügung
stehen der einzelplan 11 ist nicht nur
der größte etat im bundeshaushalt er ist
doch derjenige der in den letzten
jahrzehnten am schnellsten gewachsen ist
annähernd jeder dritte euro den die
erwerbstätigen erwirtschaften wird hier
umverteilt und da die demografische
krise sowohl die korona als auch die
ukraine krise bei weitem in den schatten
stellen wird gilt es in den nächsten
jahren auch hier strukturell
nachzubessern
eines kann man gar nicht oft genug
wiederholen und verdeutlichen wir werden
und müssen die schuldenbremse im
kommenden jahr wieder einhalten das ist
ein großer liberaler erfolg und aus
gründen der generationengerechtigkeit
zwingend erforderlich
und das ist keine wie hier gestern im
plenum geäußerte laune des
finanzministers sondern teil unseres
grundgesetzes
unser ziel ziel darf selbstverständlich
nichts an den sozialstaat einfach zu
kürzen vielmehr müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass mehr menschen wieder in arbeit
finden mehr qualifizierte arbeitskräfte
in unseren arbeitsmarkt gelangen und
unsere produktivität also das
immunsystem
unserer volkswirtschaft dadurch gestärkt
wird nur so können wir resilient werden
gegenüber der demografischen und anderen
möglichen krisen die noch auf uns warten
und nun noch ein wort an die
bundesländer
ich bin absolut empört darüber dass der
vom bund mitfinanzierten härtefall form
für jüdische zuwanderer auch im jahr
2023 wieder an den ländern scheitert
eine halbe milliarde euro hätte der bund
zur verfügung gestellt was tun die
länder sie haben den bms nicht einmal
auf die letzte formale anfrage
geantwortet
auch die ampel haushälter haben mehrfach
angemahnt dass eine schnelle lösung her
muss seit mai sind wir aber lediglich
vertröstet worden das ist bei diesem
wichtigen thema wirklich tragisch gerade
funk
gerade vor dem hintergrund dass die
länder gegenüber dem bund deutliche
einnahme überschüsse aufweisen die halbe
milliarde wird nun haushalterisch
verpuffen das geht besser liebe
ministerpräsidenten im
ministerpräsidenten es wäre im übrigen
schön gewesen wenn sie den wichtigen
haushaltsdebatten zumindest in teilen
ihre präsenz erwiesen
vor uns liegen nun wirklich intensive
wochen der beratung und eines ist in
diesem jahr wirklich fundamental gerade
weil unsere volkswirtschaft so stark ist
können wir uns diesen zu sozialetat
leisten das gut so aber es ist gar nicht
auszudenken wenn bäckereien und
blumenläden unser leistungsstarker
mittelstand und die industrien im winter
muss vorübergehend ihre arbeit
einstellen müssten denn dann mangel
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen wäre
nicht nur unser wohlstand sondern auch
unser sozial etat gefährdet ich danke
saudi-arabischen betont hier nochmal die
nötig kite zur rückkehr zur
schuldengrenze
bundesarbeitsministeriums heil hat sich
zuletzt da doch etwas anders geäußert
wenn wir in eine massive rezension
schlitter muss man die frage ob die
schuldenbremse einzuhalten ist in der
koalition neu bewerten sagte er noch im
juli
ist der größte des bundeshaushaltes das
wurde gesagt und ich will auch
eindrücklich sei ausdrücklich sagen dass
wir als linke es richtig finden dass es
einen zuschuss von 1 100 12,4 milliarden
euro für die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung gibt das findet
unterstützung
das problem ist nur wenn sie diesen
zuschuss aktien vom gesamt etat bleiben
etwas über 50 milliarden euro für arbeit
und soziales übrig und gestern haben wir
ja über den einzelplan 14 also rüstung
verteidigung gesprochen nach nato
kriterien sind in diesem einzelplan 64
milliarden euro und ich finde dass das
ein missverhältnis hier gehört
nachgesteuert
meine damen und herren
14 millionen menschen leben in armut das
ist ein
negativrekord ein rekord den wir niemals
hinnehmen werden unser ziel ist es dass
in unserem reichen land menschen nicht
in armut leben dürfen und es ist möglich
mit einem gerechten steuersystem und
dafür kämpfen wir
dann muss man sich einmal die frage
stellen warum sind denn so viele
menschen in unserem land seit
1998 mit einer unterbrechung von vier
jahren war die sozialdemokratie immer an
der regierung beteiligt und hat immer
die ressorts für arbeit soziales und so
weiter verwaltet wenn wir aber uns die
entwicklung anschauen sehen wir dass die
anzahl der armen gewachsen ist die
anzahl der empfänger von grundsicherung
im alter hat sich seit 2001 verdoppelt
das kann doch nicht sein aber ich kann
ihnen erklären wie es dazu gekommen ist
mit den hartz iv gesetzen haben sie
schlecht bezahlte arbeit geschaffen und
nur gute arbeit sichert gute rente meine
damen und herren wir als linke fordern
keine armutsfeste rente menschen die 40
jahre eingezahlt haben sollen mit 60
jahren in rente gehen können was wäre
gerecht meine damen und herren
das
entlastungspaket ist ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein durch die galoppierende
inflation selbst aufgezogen wer zb als
alleinerziehende und das sind ja in der
regel frauen zwei kinder zu versorgen
hat wird nicht einmal zur hälfte
entlastet wer soll eigentlich ihrer
meinung nach die andere hälfte bezahlen
meine damen und herren der hartz4 satz
so auf 500 euro angehoben werden das
reicht natürlich überhaupt nicht der
paritätische wohlfahrtsverband
fordert einen hartz-iv-satz von
678 euro wir unterstützen das wir sagen
687 aber das ist die richtige forderung
die wir voll und ganz unterstützen wir
wollen dass haushalte mit niedrigen und
mittleren einkommen ein jahr lang
monatlich
125 euro plus 50 euro für jedes
familienmitglied erhalten wir wollen in
unserem land gerechtigkeit armut nehme
ich den kindern
soweit ich der vertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken gesine
lötzsch auf sie folgt nur kathrin
michael mitglied im haushaltsausschuss
und mitglied der spd fraktion
der präsident sehr geehrter herr
minister liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
fashion week linie akt
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat in seiner
starken rede die er gestern hier genau
an dieser stelle hielt sehr recht als er
sagte in schweren zeiten wächst unser
land über sich hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition uns unter zu haken wenn
es schwierig wird und genau in dieser
tradition stehen auch die verhandlungen
um den bundeshaushalt für das kommende
jahr wir sind nur zusammen stark das
gilt für die zusammenarbeit in der
koalition und zwischen den
demokratischen fraktionen im deutschen
bundestag wie auch für unsere
gesellschaft insgesamt
die einlassungen der kolleginnen und
kollegen aus der opposition zeigen aber
auch heute ganz deutlich lauter worte
polemisches schüren von ängsten bis an
den rand der erträglichkeit
konstruktiven vorschläge fehlanzeige
in einer derart schwierigen lage in der
sich unser land aktuell befindet ist
konstruktive zusammenarbeit auch und
gerade aus der opposition heraus nicht
nur eine staatstragende geste meine
damen und herren sondern unser aller
pflicht denn es geht um viel es geht um
die zukunft unseres landes es geht um
die zukunft unseres arbeitsmarktes
unserer wirtschaft und es geht um
unseren wohlstand
es gab zeiten als standen
haushaltsdebatten nicht so mittelpunkt
des öffentlichen interesses
heute ist das aus besagten gründen
anders viele menschen haben
existenzängste sorgen sich vor der
nächsten nebenkosten und stromabrechnung
viele menschen fürchten um ihren
arbeitsplatz oder um ihr unternehmen
und wir dürfen doch nicht eine sekunde
vergessen wer dies verschuldet hat es
ist putin der sein
abscheulichen krieg weiter fortführt und
dass putin der seine energiepolitik ganz
gezielt gegen uns einsetzt
die bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten doch
zu recht dass wir ihn sicherheit bieten
dazu hat die bundesregierung am
vergangenen wochenende bereits das
dritte entlastungs paket beschlossen und
das hat es wirklich in sich und auch für
das jahr 20 23 ist es an uns ein
haushalt aufzustellen der diese
geforderte sicherheit finanziell
ermöglicht wir lassen niemanden allein
mit seinen herausforderungen und seinen
ängsten und wir müssen alle und alles im
blick haben das ist für mich
verantwortungsvolles handeln
im einzelplan 11 kommt dabei wieder eine
besondere bedeutung zu der aktuelle
entwurf sieht ausgaben in höhe von 163
milliarden euro vor das ist eine hohe
summe doch wir haben auch viel vor am
ersten januar werden wir schrittweise
das bürgergeld einführen und das ist ein
echter paradigmenwechsel wir starten mit
einem regelsatz von 500 euro und wir
erfüllen ja auch nicht nur einfach unser
sprechen unser versprechen aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
wir wollen dass diese reform ein erfolg
wird und sie wird ein großer erfolg vor
allem und ganz konkret für diejenigen
die unterstützung benötigen um schnell
wieder in arbeit zu kommen die
einführung des bürgergelds bedeutet eben
nicht nur eine namensänderung oder
regelsatzerhöhung
bürgergeld bedeutet unter anderem die
entfristung des sozialen arbeitsmarktes
mehr gezielte weiterbildung und vor
allen dingen
individualisierte betreuung auf
augenhöhe meint augenhöhe melden
und genau dafür benötigen wir genügend
finanzielle mittel sonst wird der
soziale arbeitsmarkt einen weiteren
rückgang erfahren und das können wir uns
nicht leisten wir müssen hier fördern
fördern fördern und das schaffen wir nur
wenn die jobcenter auch auskömmlich
ausgestaltet sind
26 februar sind hunderttausende menschen
aus der ukraine zu uns nach deutschland
gekommen putin führt weiter krieg gegen
die ukraine und wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass
diese betreuungsleistung
umfangreich und vor allem eine
dauerhafte mehrbelastung für die
kolleginnen und kollegen der jobcenter
bedeutet nur um hier mal eine größe
einzuordnen vor dem rechtskreis wechsel
ins sgb 2 im mai diesen jahres wurden
von den jobcentern 3,5 millionen
erwerbsfähige leistungsberechtigte
betreut nach dem rechtskreis wechsel der
übrigens sehr zügig und geräuschlos
vollzogen wurde stieg die zahl im august
schon auf 3,8 millionen und dafür an
dieser stelle auch mal ein herzlicher
dank an die kolleginnen und kollegen der
jobcenter für ihre fantastische arbeit
gemeinsam mit meinen schätzt mit beritt
mit berichterstatter kolleginnen werden
wir in den kommenden verhandlungswochen
lösungswege aufzeigen damit wir diesen
umständen gesamtbudget des sgb 2
rechnung tragen und eine auskömmliche
finanzierung
sicherstellen können willy brandt sagte
der beste weg die zukunft vorauszusagen
ist sie zu gestalten und gestalten
werden wir indem wir mit diesem haushalt
die wesentlichen weichenstellungen
vornehmen und rahmenbedingungen für den
sozialen zusammenhalt und ein
solidarisches miteinander setzen das
sicherzustellen ist unsere verantwortung
unsere gemeinsame verantwortung denn nur
gemeinsam sind wir stark herzlichen dank
und glückauf
nicht drin als der kollege peter müller
cdu zu
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dieser haushalt
des bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales zeigt deutlich dass die
ampelkoalition herr minister an den
sorgen und nöten der menschen in unserem
land vorbei regiert die entlastungs
paket
im frühjahr waren wenig angemessen
sie haben wichtige teile und zur
bevölkerung vergessen da musst du musst
du das ja heute in seiner rede
eingestehen wir haben von anfang an
darauf hingewiesen dass die rentner und
studenten vergessen haben und bei ihren
stundenlangen verhandlungen dann
verschiedene sätze 200 und 300 wer weiß
warum die so zustande gekommen ist
heizen und ein warmes zuhause brauchen
die einst elvis deswegen ist es gut dass
ich ab und zu auf uns hören uns dass wir
beim wippen entlastungspaket genauso
wichtig ein ganzheitliches denken herr
minister und liebe kollegen der ampel
koalition fehlt vollkommen alleine die
kritik der verbände mal anschaut
kinderreiche familien fordern den
ausgleich von energiekosten ab dem
dritten kind die lebenshilfe mahnt an
nachbesserungen
beim energiepaket für menschen mit
behinderung die werkstätten hat mir der
wilfried eggers mit auf den weg gegeben
für menschen behindert mit behinderung
wurden vergessen in ihrem paket und alle
bei allen einzelmaßnahmen vergessen sie
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren vor
allem die mittelschicht in unserem land
ins auge zu nehmen
und dass wir ein ganz wesentlicher
aspekt wir haben ja heute angekündigt
bekommen dass es anscheinend einen
schutzschirm für unsere unternehmen
geben soll wenn der schutzschirm genau
so verkorkst wird wird die gasanlage
dann wird es sicherlich eine große
freude für die unternehmen in unserem
land meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren eines wird durch
eines meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren wir durch ihre politik sehr
deutlich dass sie die grundprinzipien
der sozialen marktwirtschaft dass sie
die grundprinzipien der sozialen
marktwirtschaft auswählen zwei beispiele
zwei beispiele hierzu bundesminister
habe und ihre ampel koalition meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren nehmen
explizit in kauf ich zitiere ihren
minister dass es sozial politische
unwuchten geben kann die man dann
irgendwie mal wieder ausgleichen muss
dieser ausgleich meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren steht bis heute aus und
die umverteilung jahre lang na ja also
wir haben auf jeden fall man könnte
vielleicht in so einer schwierigen phase
haben und eingestehen dass man
nachbessern und nicht von unten nach
oben verteilt es grundprinzip dass unser
unsere politik auf jeden fall nicht ist
und die sie wahrscheinlich auch falsch
auf den weg bringen dann zum thema hartz
4 das durch die spd die grünen und die
fdp abgeschafft werden soll das ist
denke ich ist eine falsche reaktion das
ist
also wenn ich die zitate der spd
anschaue dann heißt das wir schafften
arzt hier auch wenn das nicht wenn das
nicht so also dann ist das so also das
ist die falsche reaktion wenn man den
arbeitsmarkt anschauen das so erklärt
sich auch die äußerung des bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten
wir brauchen eine aktivierende
arbeitsmarktpolitik da ist ausbildung
sicherlich ein wesentlicher impuls und
die leistungs ansätze die hier mit
eingebracht werden und wenn man sich
dann sehr geehrter herr kurt ihre rede
anhört mit ihrer gespielten aufregung
und ihre fraktionsvorsitzende hat das ja
haben dienstag genauso gemacht dann ist
es tatsächlich etwas schwieriges dass
man aus meiner sicht ich machen sollte
ich habe
geld ich habe gerade die google jürgen
es war eine der bekanntesten
griechischen philosophen die es gab und
ich habe ein zitat von ihm gefunden das
sehr gut auf die politik gehen wir aus
der sonne dieser welt nicht so gut
gepasst sondern ein anderes sehr kurz
neben mir nicht was du mir nicht geben
kannst ich glaube das ist ein gutes
zitat des der sie beruft jugend ist auf
den weg gebracht hat genau das machen
sie nicht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der ampel sie nehmen den menschen weg
gras oder ein letztes beispiel und
wissen nicht immer zurückgeben soll in
so einer schwierigen zeit deswegen
machen sie eine bessere politik dass die
anleger vertrauen in die politik der
applikation finden herzlich ein
als nächster nähe das wort die kollegin
beate müller gemmeke bündnis 90 die
grünen
der präsident herr minister kolleginnen
und kollegen wir beraten den haushalt
und gleichzeitig arbeiten wir an der
zentralen arbeitsmarktreform der
ampelkoalition wir wollen mit dem
bürgergeld jahr her aber wir wollen
hartz 4 überwinden und ein neues system
schaffen das auch würde augenhöhe und
vertrauen setzen da geht es natürlich
und die soziale absicherung aber
arbeitslose menschen brauchen vor allem
auch neue chancen und perspektiven und
die entstehen nur durch individuelle
individuelle passende angebote und
unterstützung und deshalb werden wir
auch bei der arbeitsförderung richtig
viel verändern
mitteln
mit dem geld werden wir wichtige
angebote stärken wir werden auch neue
leistungen einführen beispielsweise ein
weiterbildungsgeld wurde eine
ganzheitliches coaching mehr
weiterbildung das schrittweise
heranführen an den arbeitsmarkt sozialer
teilhabe
all das kostet natürlich geld und doch
sollen die mittel um 600 millionen euro
gekürzt werden und auch das kritisieren
wir denn das würde gerade die in
sozialen arbeitsmarkt treffen ein
erfolgreiches instrument das
perspektiven schafft würde dann nicht
mehr richtig funktionieren und es darf
nicht sein denn wir dürfen die menschen
die besonders lange keine arbeit haben
nicht alleine lassen
wir brauchen
wir brauchen also eine gute finanzielle
ausstattung im sgb 2 und dafür gibt es
auch gute gründe wir brauchen die mittel
weil jede weiterbildung jede
qualifizierung neue chancen schaffen es
gibt die geflüchtete menschen aus der
ukraine sie sind schon angesprochen
worden die zu den jobcentern gewechselt
sind und die müssen jetzt qualifiziert
werden damit sie eben nicht im system
hängen bleiben und außerdem haben wir ja
noch den arbeitskräftemangel und die
antwort darauf sind eben nicht
sanktionen wie herr merz und die union
immer wieder vorschlagen die antworten
auf der arbeitskräftemangel sind
unterstützung ausbildung weiterbildung
und qualifizierung
und an dieser stelle zu sparen wäre
absolut denn es ist immer teurer wenn
menschen im bürgergeld feststecken
anstatt sie zu unterstützen und sinnvoll
zu qualifizieren und deshalb dürfen die
mittel im sgb 2 nicht gekürzt werden der
eingliederungs etat muss im gegenteil
sogar gestärkt werden und wenn das mit
der schuldengrenze und wenn das mit der
schuldenbremse nicht möglich ist dann
müssen wir eben uns fragen ob diese
schuldenbremse heute noch in die zeit
passt das bürgergeld mit seinem konzept
darf nicht nur auf dem papier stehen das
muss gerade jetzt in der schwierigen
zeit auch tatsächlich bei den menschen
ankommen und dafür werden wir uns
engagiert einsetzen vielen dank
die anti müller gemmeke war das für
bündnis 90/die grünen und auf sie
folgten ulrike zu singen sie sitzt für
die fdp fraktion im haushaltsausschuss
und auch im ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
herr präsident liebe kollegen verehrte
bürger ganz europa steckt knietief in
der krise aber wenn wir einen blick
hinter die grenzen werfen dann stellen
wir fest andere länder kommen damit
besser zurecht das war so während der
pandemie und das ist auch jetzt so wenn
es darum geht die folgen des ukraine
krieges zu bewältigen
das alles müsste nicht sein denn das
elend ist hausgemacht nach ihrer
kopflosen für ohne politik zwingen sie
nun mit ihrer unsinnigen energiewende
eine ganze industrie nation in die knie
entgegen aller vernunft und
notwendigkeit die sozialen folgen nehmen
sie billigend in kauf die viertgrößte
industrienationen der welt ist nicht
mehr in der lage für grundlegendsten
bedürfnisse der bürger zu sorgen für
strom wasser und wärme stattdessen
debattieren sie allen ernstes über
zentrale wärme hallen und geben über
griffige ratschläge zur körperhygiene es
ist gut dass sie nun endlich geld in die
hand nehmen um zumindest irrt und da die
allerhöchste not zu lindern
doch das reicht hinten und vorne nicht
ein großer teil der entlastungen sind ja
lediglich überschaubare
einmalzahlungen oder temporärer verzicht
auf weitere belastungen die sie den
bürgern nur etwas später zumuten wollen
siehe co2 umlage jede aufgabe als
regierung ist es aber für bezahlbare
energie zu sagen und die ursachen der
inflation zu bekämpfen
dann bräuchte es auch keine
entlastungspaket für die sie den bürgern
das geld vorher aus der tasche gezogen
haben warum erzähle ich das falls ich
all diese krassen politischen
fehlentscheidungen in fataler weise auf
den arbeitsmarkt und damit auch auf die
sozialen sicherungssysteme auswirken die
zeiten in der die regierung sämtliche
probleme mit geld zuschütten konnte das
sie zuvor dem mittelstand abt reste sind
endgültig vorbei nur sie haben das noch
nicht verstanden es sind ja vor allem
deutsche unternehmen die unter den
horrenden steuern abgaben umweltauflagen
und jetzt auch noch den explodierenden
energiekosten leiden großkonzerne können
ihre produktion ins ausland verlagern
und das tun sie auch unsere
mittelständischen unternehmen können das
nicht das ergebnis für viele betriebe
rentiert sich die produktion nicht mehr
viele menschen werden deshalb nicht nur
in kurzarbeit gehen sondern ihre arbeit
ganz verlieren im einzelplan 11 über den
wir heute reden findet sich übrigens
nichts davon gerade einmal 200 millionen
euro zusätzlich sind vor allem g2 und
heizkosten eingeplant das reicht hinten
und vorne nicht
auf meiner sommertour durch mein
wahlkreis erzählte mir eine verkäuferin
dass sie sich überlegt ihren job an den
nagel zu hängen weil sie jetzt nicht
mehr weiß wie sie das alles bezahlen
soll ihr traut vor dem winter aber mit
hartz4 würde der staat wenigstens fürs
wohnen und die heizung sorgen das heißt
wir sind in deutschland tatsächlich so
weit dass sich die menschen selbst das
arbeiten nicht mehr leisten können auf
diese art werden millionen arbeitnehmer
entmutigt und zur almosen empfängern
degradiert wollen sie das wer wird dann
noch die steuern und die beiträge
erwirtschaften um das hausgemachte elend
ihrer politik zu lindern im sinne der
nachhaltigkeit müssten sie nun
eigentlich alles dafür tun um mehr
menschen in arbeit zu bekommen aber das
tun sie nicht bekanntermaßen sind
derzeit rund 2,5 millionen menschen
arbeitslos in unserem land gleichzeitig
war noch nie so viele stellen unbesetzt
es fehlen vor allem facharbeiter aber
auch für einfache hilfstätigkeiten
findet sich kaum jemand mehr ich frage
mich ob es in dieser situation eine gute
idee ist die leistung für die
eingliederung langzeitarbeitsloser um
600 millionen euro zu kürzen und auf
diese frage muss erlaubt sein wie ist es
möglich dass nach jahren der
kostspieligen integration der
sprachförderung und ausbildung von
millionen zuwanderern anscheinend
niemand in der lage ist am flughafen
koffer zu sortieren oder in der
gastronomie auf zu helfen die einzige
antwort ist dass ihr sämtliche
steuerungssysteme versagen und
fehlanreize wirken die nun auch noch
zementiert werden sollen in dem sich das
geplante bürgergeld zunehmend als
einstieg in das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen entpuppt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn sich
arbeit nicht mehr lohnt dann können wir
hier im land das licht ausmachen das
gilt im übrigen auch für die
altersvorsorge millionen menschen müssen
derzeit zu sehen wie ihre sparpläne und
betriebsrenten täglich weniger wert sind
hier werden ganze lebensplanung ruiniert
wir werden eine neue welle der
altersarmut erleben auch das ist eine
folge ihrer politik umso wichtiger
sollte es sein die gesetzliche rente zu
stabilisieren aber im haushalts- wurf
kann ich die dafür gesetzlich
vorgesehenen 500 millionen euro nicht
finden und auch die voll möglich
vollmundig angekündigten 10 milliarden
euro als einstieg in die kapitalgedeckte
ergänzung zur umlagefinanzierung der
rente fehlen das ist keine
vorausschauende politik sondern eine
kapitulationserklärung vor der zukunft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so kann
das nicht weitergehen ich habe diese an
sie von den ampel parteien warfen sie
auf befreien sie unser land aus dem
würgegriff der selbstzerstörung und
ihrer ideologisch fehlgeleiteten politik
vielen dank
vielen dank kollegin sie gezielt in
das wort erhält nunmehr der kollege jens
beeck fdp fraktion jens beeck ist
teilhabe politischer sprecher seiner
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber der
minister sei meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren kolleginnen und kollegen sie
sehen von der opposition auch bei uns
der ein oder andere hat noch einen
wunsch das ist und sozialpolitikern
immer nennt wir haben immer noch eine
gute idee wo wir etwas mehr machen
könnten aber wenn ich den blick noch
einmal auf das lenken darf was heute
hier diskutiert wird nämlich der jetzige
haushalt mit 163 3 milliarden euro im
ersten entwurf
dann ist das über ein drittel mehr als
noch vor zehn jahren oder umgekehrt vor
zehn jahren als basis ist es 50 prozent
mehr das könnte man sagen ja gab
inflation alles ist teurer geworden es
ist auch der anteil am gesamthaushalt
des bundes mit
36,6 prozent der größte den b hatten und
daran erkennen sie die ernsthaftigkeit
dieser fortschritts koalition im bereich
des sozialstaates geld einzusetzen um zu
verbesserungen zu kommen und da sind wir
uns sehr einig und wir legen mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf gewaltig vor meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren da gibt es
eine vielzahl von themen
sie können ja sagen was daran falsch es
wir können das diskutieren warum ein
faktencheck also es ist der größte
anteil den wir jemals hatten das machen
wir als spd grüne fdp koalition und das
zeigt die ernsthaftigkeit die wir haben
gesagt dass noch einmal an dieser stelle
und die aufgaben sind in der tat riesig
und sie haben recht herr kollege gröhe
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass die
zehn milliarden schon drin sind aber
dass wir in der rente die aufgabe haben
für alle bezieherinnen das system zu
sichern und dass dafür ein
kapitalgedeckter stock der richtige weg
ist wer sind wir uns doch einig und wenn
sie sehen dass
ich rede auch gar nicht mit ihnen lieber
kollege matthias wie die fahrräder mit
dem kollegen grüne gerade habe ich habe
ausdrücklich gesagt und dass sich nicht
alle einig sind ist ja auch klar aber es
ist vereinbart wir werden das machen an
vielen reden hier hat man ja kann die
sich gar nicht so richtig auf den
haushalt des bmbf kapriziert haben dass
wir verschiedene krisen in diesem land
zu bewältigen haben und das sorgt auch
dafür dass man einen koalitionsvertrag
in der geschwindigkeit abarbeiten kann
wie man sich das wünschen würde aber es
ist eine frage der
generationengerechtigkeit dass wir das
machen und wir haben das vereinbart und
wir werden das machen und angesprochen
wurden ist die bürger geld reform
auch dafür das sind die nächsten
26 28 prozent ich sind immer weniger im
haushalt
auch dafür nehmen wir richtig geld in
die hand und es sind dinge die wir alle
gemeinsam immer schon wussten dass es
eine vielzahl von bürokratie gibt die
erstens die zielgenauigkeit
verhindert von leistungen die wir im
bereich alg 2 sgb 12 erbringen die
verhindert dass es transparent und
nachvollziehbar also verstellbar ist für
diejenigen die
leistungserbringer sind und für
diejenigen die leistungsberechtigte sind
ich behaupte nach wie vor der kirche mit
widerspruch niemand kann in der
komplexen situation den hals fiel satz
richtig genau auf den cent ausrechnen
und das wollen wir ändern durch
entbürokratisierung der minister hat es
angesprochen ums nachvollziehbarer zu
machen um es einfacher zu machen
übrigens auch um unsere verwaltung zu
entlasten die damit überlastet sind und
am ende zu einer verbesserung der
leistungen zukommen mit dem wir das geld
einsetzen für diejenigen die es brauchen
und nicht wie unsere bürokratie auch das
haben wir uns vorgenommen und das werden
wir tun und das hat übrigens etwas mit
würde zu tun denn jeder der wie viele
von uns im sozialrecht anwaltlich oder
sonst gearbeitet hat kennt auch diese
fragen die am ende auf kommen mit x 18
monate die kontoauszüge vorlegen mit der
frage wie lebt man eigentlich in welcher
konstellation mit dem zusammen das alles
brauchen wir nicht wenn wir es schaffen
leistungsgerechte schon teil
pauschalierte aber jedenfalls zielgenaue
ohne auf die intimsphäre der betroffenen
abstellen de fragen zukommen leistung zu
kreieren das nehmen wir uns vor und das
wäre ein riesen fortschritt in diesem
land meine sehr verehrten damen und her
jetzt haben die eigentlich gar nicht so
viel über das gesprochen deswegen wollte
nämlich über inklusion das ist immer so
das problem auch das wie bei mir das ist
ja kern des haushalts im wms und
kernaufgabe im bundesministerium
tatsächlich bleiben ja kaum zwei prozent
freie spitze trotzdem wachsen die mittel
in diesem jahr auf von 504 auf über 508
millionen euro auch an dieser stelle
zeigen wir dass wir vieles vor allem ich
bin sehr überzeugt davon dass wir bei
dem assistenz unter gesetz der
gesetzlichen verankerung noch im jahr
2023 erste fortschritte sogar im jahr
2022 noch deutlich weiter kommen wir
werden inklusion würden sport in dieser
gesellschaft ganz anders aufstellen als
das bisher der fall gewesen ist da geht
es gar nicht immer nur um haushalterisch
unterlegung sondern darum die
initiativen die es an vielen stellen
schon gibt meint 3 sport und im emsland
ist da vorbildlich das werden wir
fördern und wir werden dafür sorgen dass
diese selbstverständliche teilhabe in
der gesellschaft weiter kommt und
deswegen hier minister wir freuen uns
sehr auf die aufgaben die wir haben das
mit mich immer ganz einfach in der
diskussion aber uns einst gemeinsam mit
ziel wir werden da vorbeikommen letzter
satz ich freue mich sehr dass andere
ministerien das mittlerweile auch
erkannt hat im bundesministerium für
digitales und vatis vortag stattgefunden
und der es überschrieben mit barrieren
müssen weg genau das machen wir
gemeinsam auch in diesem haus herzlichen
dank für die auch
jens beeck hat gesagt dass man als
sozialpolitiker immer noch einen wunsch
habe was man besser machen könnte aber
hat dann doch insgesamt sehr viel
zustimmung zu diesem etat entwurf
gezeigt und nächste reden ist jessica
ttc sprecherin für arbeitsmarktpolitik
der linksfraktion
herr präsident kolleginnen und kollegen
herr minister sie loben sich ja selbst
am meisten für das geplante bürgergeld
beratung auf augenhöhe mehr mitsprache
von arbeitslosen auf ihrem weg zurück in
arbeit mehr wertschätzung für die
beschäftigten in den jobcentern aber wo
findet sich das im haushalt sehen wir
uns die verwaltungskosten der jobcenter
an die jobcenter haben 2021 fast sechs
milliarden euro für ihre verwaltung
gebraucht aber sie starten sie für das
kommende jahr nur mit fünf milliarden
aus also gleich viele hartz 4 empfänger
sollen besser beraten werden mit einer
milliarde weniger
das kann nicht hinhauen die fehlende
milliarde
lösen sich die stadt selber woanders
wohnen und sie können sie sich nur bei
den eingliederungsmittel holen also aus
dem topf der dazu da ist menschen wieder
in arbeit zu bringen minister hai mit
ihrer planung zwingen sie die jobcenter
sie zwingen sie genau das auch zu tun
die gelder fehlen dann bei beruflichen
weiterbildungen und sie fehlen bei
anderen förderungen wie dem sozialen
arbeitsmarkt und dann kürzen sie die
eingliederungsmittel nochmal über 600
millionen euro also das ist doch absurd
damit nehmen sie den menschen im harz
wir auch noch die letzte hoffnung auf
einen job noch dazu wollen sie die leute
mit einer mini erhöhung der regelsätze
um gerade mal 50 euro abspeisen inmitten
der krassesten inflation und das auch
erst ab januar warum das erhöhen sie
doch die regelsätze einfach lässt die
wahrheit ist während spd und grüne von
augenhöhe respekt und würde reden opfern
sie eiskalt die gelder für arbeitslose
der schuldenbremse was die
schuldenbremse angeht sind hubertus heil
und christian lindner ein herz und eine
seele
kolleginnen und kollegen alle zahlen
zeigen die jobcenter haben bereits
vorsorglich mit dem sparen begonnen
weiterbildungen und geförderte
arbeitsplätze werden nur noch zögerlich
vergeben die förderzahlen sinken sie
sparen den sozialen arbeitsmarkt kaputt
eine förderung für die sie sich haben
feiern lassen minister hey das ist nicht
der versprochene respekt das ist eine
verdammt miese politik auf dem rücken
von arbeitslosen
aufgang
kubicki bundestags-vizepräsident hört
man hier immer schon nur wenn die
rednerinnen und redner zu lange sprechen
dann klopfte immer ganz gern an das pult
mit mehr oder weniger erfolg dass diese
dann ihre räte schnell beenden
da herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren unsere gesellschaft hat es mit
großen wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
herausforderungen zu tun die explosion
des gaspreises der generelle anstieg der
energiepreise und als folge die rekord
inflation
und die regierung unter bundeskanzler
olaf scholz handelt seit monaten werden
alternativen zu russischem gas voran
gibt acht und mit zwei entlastungspaket
wurden die bürgerinnen und bürger um
insgesamt rund 30 milliarden euro
entlastet und in dieser woche hat die
ampelkoalition das dritte entlastungs
paket vereinbart dieses dritte
entlastungspaket ist ein großer wurf mit
65 milliarden ist es doppelt so groß wie
die beiden ersten zusammen damit geben
wir fast 100 milliarden euro aus und die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten
dieses würde entlastet gibt es aber auch
mutig weil es in die preisbildung auf
den energiemärkten eingreift und
sicherzustellen dass der grundbedarf an
strom und heizen für bürgerinnen und
bürgern unternehmen wieder bezahlbar
wird und das entlastungspaket ist
zielgerichtet und sozial ausgewogen denn
es profitieren rentner und studierende
die arbeiten der mitte geringverdiener
und bürgerinnen und bürger die auf
grundsicherung angewiesen sind unsere
botschaft heißt deutschlandpaktes und
zwar solidarisch wir lassen niemanden
allein
ich finde
finde es schon bemerkenswert dass wir
heute für sozialpolitische ratschläge
von der union wieder bekommen haben ich
kann nur sagen für mich ist das nicht
glaubwürdig ich erinnerte mich gut an
die letzten acht jahre große koalition
ja lieber hermann gröhe es war nicht
alles schlecht aber jeder
sozialpolitische fortschritt wusste mit
mühe gegen sie gegen euch durchgesetzt
werden und
nein ich frag mich auch wie glaubwürdig
ist dass sie sind doch die partei die
will dass der solidaritätszuschlag auch
noch für die obersten fünf prozent
abgeschafft wird sie sind auch die
partei
die hier den mindestlohn von 12 euro
nicht zugestimmt hat und sie sind doch
die partei die sich als wir in der
letzten wahlperiode in der renten-
kommission über die zukunft der rente
gesprungen haben nicht bereit war dazu
zu bekennen dass wir das rentenniveau
dauerhaft sichern
also
also seien sie mal ganz ganz ruhig an
der stelle meine damen und herren dieses
entlastungs paket bietet antworten auf
die ganz akuten handlungsbedarf in
dieser krise daneben bleiben aber auch
grundsätzliche herausforderungen für den
arbeitsmarkt und den sozialen
zusammenhalt in deutschland und auch die
packen wir an zb die ungerechtigkeiten
auf dem arbeitsmarkt und lohnen da bin
ich will noch einmal dran das sind drei
wochen am ersten oktober der mindestlohn
auf 12 euro steigen dass es respekt
meine damen und herren
zum beispiel das thema fachkräftemangel
der minister hat angesprochen
fachkräftemangel bis hin zum
arbeitskräftemangel in vielen branchen
und regionen unseres landes und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass die bundesregierung
gestern ihre fachkräfte strategie auf
den weg gebracht hat mit zwei großen
feiern nämlich einmal inländischen
potenziale zu nutzen durch verschiedene
maßnahmen von der verbesserung der
ausbildung bis hin zur weiterbildung
aber auch damit dass wir endlich
einwanderung wirklich in dieses land
ermöglichen durch ein neues fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz
und
das nächste große projekt dieser ampel
koalition ist das bürgergeld da muss ich
mich schon sehr wundern als jessica team
sitzt jetzt auch schon eine weile hier
im deutschen bundestag sollte schon
wissen dass als der haushaltsentwurf
gemacht worden ist durch die
bundesregierung das bürgergeld gesetz
der entwurf noch gar nicht vorlagen das
heißt es waren noch gar nicht möglich
ein zu pflegen wie viel geld das neue
geld kosten wird das werden wir jetzt
machen in den haushaltsberatungen und
werden deswegen diesen etat entwurf auf
jeden fall verändern um das bürgergeld
zu finanzieren
ja bruder geld meine damen und herren
das bedeutet höhere regelsätze rund 500
euro ab dem ersten januar 2023 aber ein
gesetz frau kathi eingesetzt baut ich
kann daher nicht gesetzlos irgendwie
sofort den leuten geld geben ich brauche
ein gesetz wir leben doch in einem
rechtsstaat zum 1 1 23 500 euro zu aber
aber meine damen und herren es geht um
mehr als um regelsätze es geht um die
größte
arbeitsmarktpolitische und sozial
politische reform es geht um einen
kulturwandel es geht um die anerkennung
von lebensleistung einen einfacheren
zugang und beratung auf augenhöhe um ein
anderes verhältnis von bürger und staat
auch dass es eine frage von respekt
keiner soll sich schämen wenn er auf
diese hilfe angewiesen ist
vor allem
vor allem aber geht es um bessere
individuelle beratung und unterstützung
damit mehr langzeitarbeitslose den weg
in nachhaltige beschäftigung ermöglicht
wird damit der arbeitsmarkt
durchlässiger inklusive wird und wir
damit auch einen beitrag leisten um
fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen und
deshalb da geht es im kern darum die
arbeitgeber die suchen und die
langzeitarbeitslosen besser
zusammenzubringen
meine damen und herren deshalb setzen
wir auf mehr weiterbildung und anreize
dafür und was die union hier wieder
behauptet hat nämlich dass wir hier ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen schaffen
würde und dass sanktionen abschaffen und
mitwirkungspflichten wird durch
wiederholung nicht basteln konnte auch
für uns bedeuten wird selbstverständlich
mitwirkungspflichten enthalten aber
eines ist nein nein sie kommt dann kommt
ihr zu - machen wir nicht wir werden
nicht die übergroße mehrheit von über 90
der kollege ich habe ihn gerade das wort
entzogen noch einmal ich kann nicht
glauben sie mir das anschauen
wenn wir uns daran gewöhnen dass harte
zeiten einhalten also magie und anderen
dann bitte auch selbst ich finde es
nicht mehr frieren dass alle 30 sekunden
überzogen wird
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin jana
schimpfte cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
weil wir heute mit so vielen warmen
worten unseres
bundesarbeitsministers hier begrüßt
wurden vielleicht auch noch mal sagen
lieber herr heil die energie krise lösen
sie nicht nur allein mit sozialpolitik
die energie krise lösen sie indem sie
die richtigen energiepolitischen
entscheidungen treffen und dazu und dazu
gehört zum einen zum beispiel mal alle
energiereserven zu nutzen die dieses
land zu bieten hat und ich hätte mir
natürlich auch von einem
sozial und arbeitsminister gewünscht der
sie ja nun auch einmal sind dass es auch
ein paar vorschläge gibt wie diese
unternehmen durch die absolute mega
krise kommen sollen die uns jetzt gerade
bevorsteht wir wissen alle wir haben
hier im deutschen bundestag wurde 12
euro mindestlohn eingeführt durch die
bundesregierung wir haben kürzlich den
arbeitsbedingungen gesetz auf die auf
den weg gebracht wir haben
selbstverständlich abgelöst und an
abgelehnt und sie äussern kein wort dazu
wie sie eigentlich die unternehmen vor
diesen belastungen schützen wollen ich
wundere mich immer wieder auch über die
einschätzung aus diversen reihen liebe
frau rachel wenn sie sagen die betriebe
schließen jetzt vorübergehend sagen sie
doch nicht so was sie wissen ganz genau
dass das nicht der fall ist das konnten
sie vielleicht noch in der korona krise
erzählen wo es dem land noch relativ gut
ging wo die kassen noch voll waren wo
wir uns diese ganzen programme noch
leisten konnten aber es ist kein geld
mehr da auch bei den unternehmen ist
kein geld mehr da die schließen nicht
vorübergehend schließen für immer und
das was wirtschaftsminister habe ich
gesagt hat war ein schlag ins gesicht in
den gesamten deutschen mittelstand
deswegen sparen sie sich solche
äußerungen so und was wir in diesem haus
als jenes viel beschrieben wurden in
dieser debatte letztendlich ist vieles
was geplant ist gar nicht im haushalt
enthalten und das was in corona einmalig
beschlossen wurde wo wir als union auch
mitgemacht haben zu sagen okay wir
setzen die vermögensprüfung aus okay wir
machen verbesserungen beim
kurzarbeitergeld wird jetzt einfach mal
so fortgeführt ohne zu überlegen ob das
eigentlich die richtigen maßnahmen sind
die kosten der unterkunft werden massiv
steigen in diesem land durch die
steigenden energiepreise ist im haushalt
nicht abgebildet wir werden steigerungen
bei den kosten der grundsicherung haben
wenn durch den regelsatz ist auch nicht
abgebildet wir werden so planen sie es
ja auch die aktien rente ein führendes
ebenfalls nicht im haushalt enthalten
und das problem ist sie setzten völlig
falsche prioritäten
sie setzten völlig falsche prioritäten
in ihrer politik mit dem bürgergeld
führen sie brücken aus beschäftigung
statt in beschäftigung und ich sage es
wir machen was sie führen ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen ein das
ist die vorstufe zu dem was darauf
kommen wird und sie verabschieden sich
sie verabschieden sich endgültig vom
aktivierenden sozialstaat vieles ist ja
leider schon der vergangenheit geschehen
es geht weiter und lieber herr kurt
liebe hamburg da wir hier ständig über
das thema menschenbild reden und welches
bild wir denn eigentlich tatsächlich
haben ich will mal daran erinnern dass
wir eine menge getan haben in den
letzten legislaturen um bedürftige
menschen in deutschland zu unterstützen
wir sind die letzten die uns von ihnen
unterstellen lassen wir hätten kein
soziales gewissen
aber lieber an bord und auch wenn sie
jetzt bei schnappatmung kriegen ich will
sie trotzdem mit einer mit einem brief
konfrontieren den ein jobcenter bekommen
hat von einem so genannten kunden indem
nämlich drin steht für die dauer des
sanktionsmoratorium bitte ich von
vermittlungsangebote abzusehen so meine
damen und herren und sie können uns hier
unterstellen dass wir hier irgendwelche
märchen aktien aber das ist nicht der
fall solche fälle gibt es tatsächlich
und was sagen sie denn den vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in den
jobcentern die seit vielen jahren eine
hervorragende arbeit leisten und sich
jetzt eben solche sprüche anhören müssen
und was soll eigentlich diese sechs
monate vertrauens zeit wir wissen alle
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
wofür sollen die menschen eigentlich
bewahrt und geschützt werden warum geht
es hier darum jemanden schrittweise in
den arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren wofür
soll denn geschützt werden arbeit ist
doch nicht schlimm ist das tut doch
nicht weh das ist doch gut
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir hier
eine deutlich andere vorgehensweise der
vielen dank
diana schimpfte war das und meine damen
und herren sie sehen dass wir auch nach
schottland schauen aus großbritannien
gab es die beunruhigenden nachrichten
dass es um die gesundheit von queen
elizabeth der zweite nicht gut steht
deswegen schauen wir auch nach
schottland
wie bürgerinnen und bürger wir haben
heute jetzt schon einiges gehört zum
thema fachkräfte und weiterbildung und
sie liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
sind der motor der antrieb für uns und
genau aus diesem grund muss die
weiterbildung die fachkräfte strategie
breit und ressort übergreifend
aufgestellt sein und das ist sie so
vielfältig wie unsere gesellschaft ist
unsere arbeitswelt aber wie funktioniert
so eine strategie nehmen wir mal eine
uhr eine armbanduhr als beispiel die wir
machen nur machen verzeihen sie mir für
eventuelle fachliche fehler jetzt in der
ausführung des folgendem beispiel aber
wenn es um präzision geht passt das
uhrmacherhandwerk einfach hervorragend
und präzision brauchen wir hier wir
bringen die uhr her als synonym für die
strategie zum laufen der bedarf an
fachkräften dreht an der kronen also
eher erhöht und eigentlich richtig und
das bringt die spiralfeder die zahnräder
in schwung wir als andere regierung
montieren diese zahnräder mit gezielten
maßnahmen mit verschiedenen
handwerkszeug wie zb die
weiterbildungsplattform die stärkung der
weiterbildungs verbünde das bringt die
menschen verschiedener möglichkeit mehr
und ein zahnrad wird auch gezielt für
die vereinbarkeit von familie und
weiterbildung beruf eingebaut werden und
das wird dann auf das ziffernblatt
übertragen und zwar für alle sichtbar
mit wo gibt es was was kann ich machen
was gibt es überhaupt und wo wir
gebraucht wir müssen draußen und
schunkeln bewerben keinen dschungel
sondern ein kurzes schneller zu suchen
und dann finden
fachkräfte
arbeitskräfte aus nah und fern halten
unsere arbeitswelt am laufen sie bringen
uns alle voran die fachkraft die
arbeitskraft für morgen wird jetzt
ausgebildet und jetzt weitergebildet und
ein wichtiger punkt ist die
weiterbildungsmöglichkeit die
weiterbildung eben für alle zugänglich
zu machen und dieses zahnrad setzen wir
auch in dieser uhr ein flexibles zahnrad
das für uns alle die möglichkeit des
weiterkommens bietet die arbeitswelt ist
im wandel so wie es schon immer war aber
die uhr läuft jetzt schneller sie läuft
anders wir müssen handeln es pressiert
und das tun wir mit ihnen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger den
fachkräften und heute und den
fachkräften von morgen und übermorgen
und dafür stellen wir das handwerkszeug
mit diesen hauswald als auftakt
dankeschön
lena winkelmann war das für bündnis 90
die grünen auf sie folgt stefan stracke
der sprecher für arbeit und soziales der
unions funktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren inflation macht arm
und hohe inflation macht schnell an und
das trifft vor allem diejenigen die es
bereits ist schon schwer haben das sind
die geringverdiener die gar keinen job
haben aber das betrifft auch die breite
arbeiten der mitte dieser gesellschaft
und deswegen zeichnet sich gute
sozialpolitik immer dadurch aus dass sie
auf preisstabilität achtet und auch eine
gute wirtschaftspolitik macht und das
sind genau die lehrstellen auch dieser
koalition wir müssen das leben für die
mitte der gesellschaft bezahlbar halten
in diesen bereichen und ihr
entlastungspaket das kommt zunächst
einmal wichtig daher es kommt aber zu
spät und es wird zu spät
viele der angekündigten entlastungen
greifen erst zum jahresende
2022 kommen vielleicht erst 23 mitten in
der kalten jahreszeit um bis dahin
explodieren die kosten weiter und
überholen die entlastungen bevor sie
überhaupt gewährt werden und natürlich
ist es richtig und es war auch
überfällig dass sie jetzt rentnerinnen
und rentner und auch die studierenden in
das entlastungspaket mit aufnehmen was
die energiepreis pauschale angeht sie
haben diese aber bewusst ausgenommen ja
in ihren vorherigen entlastungs paketen
danach haben wir immer wieder
hingewiesen sie korrigieren dass jetzt
das erkennen wir ausdrücklich an und
natürlich ist es bei diesen
preissteigerungen die wir auf dem
energiemarkt haben richtig auf dem thema
verfügbarkeit und preis zu achten gerade
was die energiekosten angeht und die
energie und deswegen ist es falsch
gerade was das thema verfügbarkeit
angeht ganz bewusst kapazitäten aus dem
markt heraus zu nehmen und genau das tun
sie mit der atomenergie weil dieser
bundesminister der wirtschaft nicht dazu
sich hat durchringen können und diese
koalition macht es mit das die
arbeitskräfte dass jetzt ihr die
atomkraft beispielsweise in der reserve
geschickt wird
michael vassiliadis hat eine andere
haltung da dazu im deutschlandfunk sagt
er wir brauchen alles an
stromkapazitäten was wir zur verfügung
haben und zwar bis 20 24 uhr recht hat
hat er recht weil er genau weiß was das
bedeutet auch für die arbeitsplätze in
deutschland bei der strompreis bremse
vollkommen unklar in welcher höhe und
wann diese dann tatsächlich kommt also
die entlastungen schreiben sie auf aber
sie sind vollkommen unklar waren diese
tatsächlich kommen und beim gas das ist
doch die größte lehrstelle die sie in
diesem entlastungspaket haben 20
millionen menschen und viele unternehmen
lassen sie alleine bei diesem thema der
gasentwicklung und es kommt noch hinzu
mit der gasanlage belasten sie ja noch
zusätzlich die haushalte dazu das passt
alles nicht zusammen
und es ist ja richtig herr
bundesminister um jeden arbeitsplatz zu
kämpfen aber die preissteigerung kommen
an auch bei dem mittelstand bei der
mittelschicht und der arbeitenden
bevölkerung und wenn die insolvenzgefahr
steigt dann ist es wichtig dass wir auch
das thema kurzarbeit als instrument
verlängern nur gleichzeitig muss man
dann auch sagen der bundesminister dann
müssen wir auch über den notwendigen
mittel reden und nicht nur alleine auf
darlehen abgeben sondern das dann auch
auf zuschüsse waren sonst haben wir
letztendlich mit zitronen gehandelt weil
dies nur zu weiteren belastungen für
unternehmer und für die beitragszahler
führt da besteht noch handlungsbedarf im
visier
und wir wollen natürlich auch
dass langzeitarbeitslose wieder fuß
fassen gerade auch nach der colonia
cleese und da brauchen wir von ihnen
überhaupt keine nachhilfebedarf denn wir
haben in dieser koalition die wir mit
angela merkel über 16 jahre hatten waren
wir da sehr erfolgreich in diesen
bereichen was den abbau der
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
angeht aber sie sind es doch die letzte
verwaltungskosten bei den jobcentern
kürzen sie sind es doch jetzt die
integrationsleistungen um 600 millionen
euro kürzen und das bedeutet im übrigen
eine absenkung der integrations mittel
pro kopf gegenüber 2009 10 um 20 prozent
um 20 prozent ist dass der respekt gehen
sie den langzeitarbeitslosen gegenüber
bringen wir wollen mehr chancen aber
doch nicht auf diese art und weise dass
sie letztendlich die mittel für
langzeitarbeitslose absenkt das ist der
falsche weg
die spd fraktion hat dass frau doktor
tanja machalet
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der strecke geht mir wirklich
gewünscht dass sie mehr zeit darauf
verwenden uns mal zu erläutern welche
vorstellungen sie im hinblick auf den
sozialetat
also dass wir jetzt atomkraftwerke
laufen lassen sollen um die sozia um den
sozialetat zu reduzieren was ist schon
november also
beachtlich
es wäre trotzdem schön gewesen wenn sie
unserer leute hätten was die welche
vorstellungen sie im hinblick auf
unseren sozialstaat haben das haben sie
nicht getan und ich möchte auch noch mal
daran erinnern weil sie sich ja um die
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit sorgen zwar
nicht sie die 16 16 vorangetrieben haben
den sozialen markt also arbeits
vorstellung das waren wir
ja unsere aufgabe besteht jetzt darin
dafür zu sorgen dass wir durch einen
starken handlungsfähigen sozialstaat die
soziale solidarität und die
wirtschaftliche stabilität in diesem
lande gewährleisten in diesen
schwierigen zeiten genau dazu leistet
der einzelplan 11 einen großen beitrag
und wir werden natürlich das was ja auch
eingefordert haben die
entlastungsmaßnahmen jetzt schnell auf
den weg bringen ich denke das ist uns
allen klar dass wir das jetzt tun müssen
aber es geht natürlich auch darum dass
wir langfristig die strukturellen
reformen der sozialen sicherungssysteme
angehen das bürgergeld ist ein baustein
dafür und da fällt ihnen ja auch nur das
sanktionsmoratorium anders haben sie ja
auch jetzt hier ausgeführt aber auch
nicht wie sie sich das ganze vorstellen
möchte aber beim stichwort bürgergeld
und auch weil das thema kurzarbeit ja
auch eine rolle gespielt hat in den
ausführungen des ministers und auch bei
ihnen herrn stracke einfach nochmal auf
die bundesagentur für arbeit zu sprechen
kommen und ich möchte auch dass also die
haut dass die herausforderungen vor
denen die bundesagentur für arbeit steht
und das können wir uns alle vorstellen
wenn es jetzt auch wieder zu kurzarbeit
situationen kommt dass die bundesagentur
auch für die entsprechend dafür
entsprechend gewappnet ist und auch für
die kommenden herausforderungen
auch für das was wir im
koalitionsvertrag uns vorgenommen haben
nämlich die weiterentwicklung zur
weiterbildung und qualifizierung cent
uhr und natürlich auch dass die
bundesagentur den fachkräftebedarf in
den eigenen organisationen bewältigen
kann habe ich es vor allem darum jetzt
auch an dieser stelle nochmal weil wir
auch sehen was dort geleistet worden ist
im hinblick auf die kurzarbeit möchte an
dieser stelle einfach nochmal den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in der
bundesagentur dafür ganz ganz herzlich
danke sagen es war wirklich hervorragend
und wir wissen auch was mit zu bauen
können wenn wir jetzt eben auch wie eine
situation kommen wo wir kurzarbeit
auszahlen müssen und ich denke es ist in
unser aller sinne dass wir die
bundesagentur auch an der stelle so
aufstellen wie wir das so wie wir wie
sie benötigen das was die bundesagentur
benötigt und ich könnte jetzt natürlich
auch noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
gerade als renten politikerin mir
wichtig ist dass wir jetzt auch was für
die rentnerinnen und rentner aus zahlen
aber wichtiger ist mit einer fast noch
wichtiger ist was wir dass sie kompetent
schluss dass wir im herbst das
rentenniveau stabilisieren da bin ich
gespannt wie sie sich verhalten also wir
haben noch einiges vor uns in diesem
haushalt mit diesem haushalt und
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
der zugang zur kurzarbeit ist noch bis
zum jahresende
vereinfacht das hat hier tanja machalet
von der spd noch einmal gewürdigt ob sie
folgten einer cdu csu fraktion
ich packe meinen koffer sie kennen lässt
sicherlich dieses kinderspiel weil
welchen jeder spielteilnehmer
nacheinander anfühlt was er gerne den
koffer packen möchte und ja danach muss
man sich immer mehr begriffe merken und
dann kommt zu verwirrungen und
verwechslungen ihr warum erzähle ich
ihnen das nicht weil ich manchmal den
eindruck habe ehrlich gesagt dass die
aktuelle regierungskoalition
gerne dieses spiels wird sie packen in
den schulden koffer ein was sie gerne
hätten die grünen die fortsetzung des
neuen euro tickets die spd das
bürgergeld die fdp das zumindest darf
schattenhaushalte noch halbwegs zu
klingende einhaltung der schuldenbremse
und aber übersee kommt dann immer noch
im interesse des koalitionsfriedens das
ein oder andere drauf man will es allen
recht machen die schulden werden immer
mehr immer überschaubarer der schulden
körper kann man kaum mehr schieben die
nächste generation wird es ja erledigen
es ist unbestritten die aktuellen
herausforderungen sind gewaltig und
wir können auch in vielen dingen
verstehen wieso sie helfen gerade akut
helfen um den menschen im moment das
leben erträglicher zu machen die kosten
sind immens und viele kommen nicht mehr
über die runden fehler die viel arbeiten
zählen das geld kaufen nur darum angebot
im supermarkt ein die folgen der korona
pandemie lieferketten verzögerung wir
wissen auch nicht wie sich sind zukunft
entwickelt die inflation der ukraine
krieg insbesondere mit explodierenden
gas und strompreisen belasten die
menschen sehr und ich glaube kenne
eigentlich keinen der sich keine sorgen
macht und nicht überlegt ob er sich dass
künftig alles leisten kann
aber gerade deshalb
[Applaus]
aber gerade deshalb ist es so wichtig in
solchen situation dass man genau
überlegt das modell und pakete geschnürt
die geld kosten auch die folge
analysiert dass man das geld effizient
einsetzt
dass man prioritäten setzt und
prioritäten setzen das ist nicht einfach
das schmerzt und wird prioritäten setzt
der enttäuscht der täuscht den der sich
vielleicht mehr oder was anderes
versprochen hat oder wenn er sieht der
andere würden hier vorgezogen bei der
prioritätensetzung
leider gottes gehören enttäuschungen
dazu und es ist nicht so dass wir das
gerne machen nur hallo irgendjemanden
schaden würden ganz im gegenteil aber
gerade in solchen zeiten
ich frage mich wie wollen sie es denn
machen wollen sie jede paar monate mit
dem geldkoffer hier verteilen ein paar
monate gerade in solchen zeiten gehört
es dazu
einfach mut zu haben weil man es leider
nicht nur mit geld verteilen allen recht
machen kann und leider habt der eta das
aber in sozialministerium für mich da
keinerlei anhaltspunkte ich kann diesen
mut hier nicht ansatzweise irgendwo
erkennen
und klar ja
was werden sie denn machen das ist
nämlich dass das ist das problem eine
riesenshow 65 milliarden verteilen geld
das aller aller wichtigste ist natürlich
so schwer es ist genau daran zu sehen wo
die ursache sind und jetzt muss ich
ehrlich sagen diese große show für 65
milliarden verteilen hätte ich gerne mal
da gehabt wo man uns präsentiert was wir
mögen man alles macht um das angebot an
energie die vorhandenen zu bieten katar
versucht nichts rausgekommen bei anderen
ländern offensichtlich schon
das wollen wir nicht ich sag nur
ideologie offen
kohlestrom ja das kann man so ein
bisschen aber ja nicht zu viel also klar
ist wenn wir das angebot nicht erhöhen
wir die probleme nicht lösen und es wird
nicht funktionieren dass sich alle zwei
monate geld verteilen wir nicht es tut
mir leid es zu sagen
das schlimme ist aber dass so viel dran
hängt und warum diskutieren wir dann
auch leider gottes auch hier über die
energie warum ist es teil hier auch
diese debatte weil natürlich die
menschen genau das spüren weil sie sich
nicht sozialer als auch ein mensch es
sich nicht leisten kann mir normal
einzukaufen lebensmittel oder wasser
wohnung retten kann wenn die wirtschaft
leider gott ist sich traut explodieren
der stromkosten nicht mehr leisten kann
zu produzieren da sieht man doch im
arbeitsministerium das ist gesagt worden
was könnte die zu stärken da kommt zu
wenig zu wenig für den mittelstand und
leider die beschäftigten werden es
merken
da sind wir genau in diese meter
und deshalb komme ich ihnen raten
schmeißen wir die ökologie gebrauchen
sie können und wir unterstützen das die
transformation weitergehen aber bitte
machen sie eineinhalb jahre realpolitik
und nur das zählt für die menschen im
land denn die brauchen ihre
unterstützung und keine ideologie und
besserwisserei
es gebe noch gut zum tragen wir haben
dazu kommt noch eine zweite dritte
lebensmittel zum schluss entschieden und
uns allen dass es nicht so schlimm wird
wie es inzwischen viele
wirtschaftsexperten sagen letztes land
eine show nannte segeler das
entlastungspaket das dürfte die nächste
und hier die letzte rednerin in der
debatte anders sehen stefan häfner
spricht jetzt für bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
das ist teile dieses hauses hier gibt
die sich darüber freuen wenn es menschen
noch schlechter geht und das halt
irgendwie dummerweise offenbaren weil
sie vergessen mikros aufzumachen
zuzumachen nach debatten geschenkt
passiert aber das andere teile dieses
hauses
diese debatte auf diese art und weise
ihr heute führen das finde ich der
angemessenheit der lage in der wir uns
befinden überhaupt nicht angemessen wir
befinden uns in einer krise die den
menschen so viel sorgen bereitet wie
noch nie in diesem land ja ich komme
darauf zurück eben ihr letzter
redebeitrag redet von energie einkauf in
katar von atomkraftwerken ich dachte wir
debattieren den haushalt des bhs an
dieser stelle und machen uns darüber
gedanken
dann
dann bringen sie fakten freie
behauptungen in die debatte wie ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen was wir
hier einführen würden das sagt schon
eigentlich das wort bedingungslos wir
haben eigentlich immer noch eine
bedürftigkeitsprüfung manchmal hilft es
wenn man gesetzentwürfe über die man
debattiert auch liest bevor man menschen
wie ihr gegeneinander auf
die menschen erwarten von uns
lösungsvorschläge und sie dürfen uns
gerne kritisieren aber dann bringen sie
ernsthaft auch wirklich ihre vorschläge
in die debatte ein dann freuen wir uns
auf der hand auseinandersetzung dazu wir
brauchen an dieser stelle jetzt zwei
dinge ja das haben sie immer wieder
angesprochen wir müssen über die preise
für energie reden aber das ist aufgabe
von anderen ressorts hier
braucht müssen wir darüber reden wie wir
die folgen des russischen
angriffskrieges
sozial abfedern an dieser stelle und
genau deshalb ist es so wichtig dass die
soziale frage in diesem haushaltsentwurf
eben beantwortet wird und wir jetzt
aktuell mit dem bürgergeld reform
gleichzeitig an einer riesen reform in
diesem bereich arbeiten kollege rosemann
hat es gesagt die aufgaben die wir uns
mit der bürgergeld reform gestellt haben
die sind noch nicht abgebildet im
haushaltsentwurf der das war ja noch gar
nicht fertig und auch die entscheidung
des entlastungspaket es vom letzten
wochenende sind eben noch nicht da drin
und genau das wird jetzt aufgabe des
parlamentarischen verfahrens sein und ja
unsere aufgabe ist es menschen angst zu
nehmen denn zur freiheit gehört auch die
zeit dazu keine angst haben zu müssen
die ich meine stromrechnung bezahlen
muss und genau das sind aufgaben die wir
uns im laufe des parlamentarischen
verfahrens zum bürgergeld stellen müssen
wie wir diese fragen lösen und da laden
wir sie herzlich ein mit uns konstruktiv
daran zu arbeiten
das war dann die erste beratung zum
einzelplan 11 arbeit und soziales von
bundesminister hubertus heil
163,3 drei milliarden euro sind im
entwurf vorgesehen für das kommende jahr
um natürlich so große fragen zu lösen
wie den fachkräftemangel eine
altersvorsorge wie die gestaltet werden
kann und auch wie die grundsicherung für
arbeitssuchende die ja kommen soll wie
die genau ausgestaltet wird